liechtenstein isn't just one of the
world's smallest countries it's one of
the most prosperous despite having just
37,000 citizens and covering just 61
square miles in Central Europe the
microstate has a per capita income of
about $100,000 a corporate flat tax of
twelve and a half percent and an income
tax of 1.2 percent now well known as a
banking and financial hub the
Principality wasn't always so flush in
fact in 1967 the royal family had sell a
prized possession Leonardo da Vinci's
first known portrait just to keep the
country afloat when I studied economics
in law and the sixties prevailing wisdom
that was that small countries like
leashed and have no future no economic
future and no political future we talked
with the country's leader
Prince Hans Adams the second at the
international students for liberty
conference in Washington DC about how
Liechtenstein turned itself around while
becoming world famous for its banking
privacy and for its openness to
immigrants and we talked about the
princes new book about the future of
government the state in the third
millennium Prince thanks for talking to
us yeah fine first off you're at the
international students for liberty
conference talk about your interest in
reaching a new generation of people who
believe in classical liberal ideals of
free minds and free markets what it also
that I wrote the book which has been on
how to stay to devolve in this third
millennium which is sort of a very
liberal or a free-market model and so
I've been invited to make speeches and
and take part in discussions so I got an
invitation to come here to one of the
things that Lichtenstein is best known
for is its banking and financial
securities sector talk a bit about the
role of Liechtenstein as a place both
where taxes were low so it acted as a
haven from other countries but then also
how by guaranteeing the privacy of the
funds there how did that not just help
Liechtenstein but how does that help the
rest of the the countries of people who
might be dealing with you it was in
used quite early and it was also
introducing and strengthened like in
Switzerland also I think after World War
one to protect political refugees
speciality Jews Jewish people who saw
the danger persecution coming or where
persecuted there it was important on how
to protect them also then afterwards
from Eastern Europe and so that was the
background but that has not been we have
been forced with some English time to
open up room so we had basically had to
abolish the banking secrecy what gets
lost when banking secrecy goes away
because in the United States often and
certainly in Europe they'll say well the
only people who want secrets are people
who have something to hide but that's
not the end of the story is it it's not
the end of the story I think we have
states where people are persecuted
people who have managed to hide some
money outside to flee to save themselves
and their family if we don't have a
certain privacy we still have it to a
certain degree but we have to give in
when there some requests right how do
you deal with immigration and this is a
fascinating question in the American
election we have the Republican Party is
incredibly hostile to immigration in
Europe we're seeing hostility or
pushback from Syrian refugees or people
from outside of Europe coming there but
also within the European Union you know
the Irish don't want Polish people
coming there and the Germans don't want
you know Italian people coming there how
do you deal with immigration in this
kind of situation what we intended a
tradition to do it quite a high level of
foreigners about 40% and as if I'm right
I think it may be the high licked and I
may have the highest percentage of
foreign-born population in here I would
say so and we also took in refugees it
and tradition to taking of course
only a certain amount II cannot take
hundred thousands into but there we have
a tradition and we have been able to
integrate them quite well with the
common European market has that been a
success or a failure in your view and or
is it coming apart because even as we
speak the British are talking about
possibly executed it seems to me that
the original idea of the European Union
to create the United States of Europe I
think that is not going to be realized
so I think on the political side
probably going to move backwards but on
the economic side I think there will be
further deepening I would imagine so
that it's Europe itself will be a large
trading bloc with either no or very few
tariffs and and yes rules between yes I
think that in your book you you discuss
how the the state should really only be
involved in a relatively few things but
do those well what are the things that
the state should be involved in and how
do you determine where that where the
role of the state ends well in my book
and also what we more is realized in
Liechtenstein through also some changes
to constitutions through direct
democracy it's basically to have the the
rule of law so that works often of
course you need foreign policy and then
you have to have the educational system
and am very much in favor of ultra
system how does that fit in with the
contemporary European and actually North
American welfare state where in the
United States for instance about
something like two thirds of all
spending is on health care is on old-age
pensions it's on transfer payments it's
it's about a social safety net as
opposed to those other things how do we
how do we change that balance as we is a
very small state we can do it ourselves
so it means that small communities like
small cities or villages even can have
their own social system and what awesome
posing is to have a separation between
indirect taxation which would be with
the state and/or direct taxation with
the local communities where you have
direct democracy also also on a state
level but that should take care of the
social expenses are you optimistic you
know there's a lot of pessimism you know
about the global marketplace you know
there the economy globally is not good
its weak in various parts of Europe the
Middle East is a nightmare China seems
to be falling North and South America
are kind of languishing are you
optimistic about the future and if so
what what drives your optimism well I
think if I look back the 20th century it
could have been much much worse
we were lucky it could have ended in
atomic war god knows what it would have
been World War 3 or whatever yeah we
still don't live in a perfect world and
and for me it was also to write the book
end and end so to try to influence in
what way we should go so that we live in
a more peaceful and prosperous world I
think that's important I think the
politicians who are influential to think
about new models how to do it how to
deal with all these problems well we
will leave it there thank you so much
for talking with us fine we've been
talking with Prince hans-adam of
Liechtenstein for Reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie